réussi endeuillé ce matin à la suite
d'une fusillade d'une fusillade qui a
éclaté à l'université de la ville de
perm à 1200 km à l'est de moscou il y
aurait au moins six morts selon le
ministère de la santé 24 blessés dont 19
par balles selon les chiffres également
des autorités heureux ce un bilan revu à
la baisse qui reste provisoire
l'assaillant qui a ouvert le feu dans
l'enceinte du bâtiment a été arrêté plus
de précisions avec notre correspondant
en cinquième
un événement tragique s'est déroulée ce
matin à perm une ville de l'oural située
à 1200 km à l'est de moscou un individu
a ouvert le feu sur le campus de
l'université faisant de nombreux morts
et blessés les vidéos diffusées sur les
réseaux sociaux montrent des personnes
en panique fuir du bâtiment par les
fenêtres probablement pour tenter
d'échapper aux tueurs je vous propose
d'écouter quelques témoignages je n'ai
pas entendu deux coups de feu mais quand
j'étais sur le point de sortir du
bâtiment de l'université il y avait déjà
un groupe de gens qui commençaient à se
rassembler certains entraide d'autres
sortaient et alors que nous allions
sortir tout le monde s'est mis à courir
à l'intérieur du bâtiment si nous avions
quitté le bâtiment 10 ou 15 minutes plus
tôt nous aurions pu nous retrouver juste
là dans cette situation je ne sais pas
ça aurait été effrayant
une foule de gens courraient et j'ai vu
un jeune homme avec un fusil qui
marchaient derrière eux est tiré je
n'arrêtais pas de penser que c'était des
exercices puis j'ai vu un homme qui
était tombé sur l'herbe qui était
allongé alors nous avons compris nous
étions trois dans le bureau que ce
n'était pas des exercices les quelque
chose de sérieux nous nous sommes
enfermés à l'intérieur dans le bureau du
doyen ça a commencé à 11h20 et nous y
sommes restés une heure jusqu'à 12h20
puis la police a frappé à la porte et
ils ont commencé à nous faire sortir
on était avec des amis à l'entrée
c'était avant les cours près de ma
voiture on a entendu des coups de feu on
s'est retourné il était là à 20 mètres
de nous avec un fusil de chasse nous
sommes dispersés on est allé dans
différentes directions il me semble que
personne n'a été touché dieu merci on
nous a tiré dessus il a touché ma
voiture tant mieux il n'y a que la
voiture qui a été endommagée nous sommes
tous sains et saufs
le tireur pour sa part été arrêté par
les forces de l'ordre qui ont déclaré
qu'il s'agissait d'un étudiant de cette
même université et qu'il était
légalement en possession d'une arme à
feu le suspect a ensuite été prise en
charge à l'hôpital son identité n'a pas
encore été rendu public mais un peu plus
tôt dans la matinée un jeune homme de
cette université aurait écrit sur le
réseau social russe contactiez sa
volonté de commettre une fusillade le
président russe à d'ores et déjà
présenté ses condoléances aux proches et
familles des victimes tandis que le
ministre de la santé et le ministre de
l'éducation ont été dépêchés sur place